I know you in there
son of a [ __ ] doesn't have a dick he's
got a [ __ ] dick
he just got a tucked in identify
yourselves [ __ ] I'm Jay and
this my head rule I've made Silent Bob
don't tell me you guys have no idea
there's a new comic book movie being
made of the old comic book movie you two
are the basis for that old a
star-studded piece of [ __ ]
that movie's some balls it's like
[ __ ] - Your Honor I object
I'll allow it that movie did suck balls
and [ __ ] we got three days to get to
Hollywood and stop this review from ever
hat boy baby
J racers you're about to me
I think I'm gonna need to see a blood
test this is my daughter can you take us
to Hollywood with you oh no man
it's a tough ass neighborhood either you
take us to Hollywood or a stab you both
to death on my own [ __ ] lawn and on
that note we cue the music
I'm glad you guys are smoking back there
I was driving someone about a week ago
and he took a big [ __ ] you have no idea
how hard it is to get the smell out of
pleather
[Music]
your methods what students
[Music]
it's Jay and Silent Bob
I just found out I have a kid but I
don't know how to be a father
anybody with [ __ ] can be a fun but only
love can make you a dad how you going to
talk about love and you flee and come
all over the place that's just see what
do you guys think about this reboot it
sucks there I said it
and who's directing this [ __ ] anyway
Kevin [ __ ] Smith smells like this
reboot and up and smooth hey Manmeet
Kevin Smith he's amused that's right
we're refugees from the 90s get ready
for our sequel to Jay and Silent Bob
strike back Jay and Silent Bob reboot
you want to see it we want to show it to
you so we're bringing it to you to your
hometown you can watch it with us and
afterwards we're gonna answer all your
questions that's right it's the Jay and
Silent Bob reboot Roadshow so come on
out and join us give us your money cuz
we got to eat this year yeah so does my
kid man so good tickets at reboot
roadshow Cobbs see you there
[Music]
you